l'idée d'un sommet des plus grands pays
industrialisés né en 1975 dans la foulée
du choc pétrolier
une première rencontre se tient au
château de rambouillet près de paris
elle réunit la france les états unis le
japon l'allemagne de l'ouest
la grande bretagne et l'italie le canada
se joint au groupe en 1976 à la
suggestion des états unis en 1998 la
russie intègre le g7 qui devient le g8
jusqu'en 2014
moscou est alors expulsé à la suite de
l'annexion de la crimée le groupe des
plus grands pays industrialisés
représentent à peu près 50% de
l'économie mondiale mais de grandes
économies comme la chine l'inde le
brésil n'en font pas partie la
présidence est tournante chaque pays
prend le leadership une année et est
responsable de l'organisation du sommet
le canada en est l'hôte pour la sixième
fois il y à eut d'abord montebello au
québec en 1981
toronto en 88 halifax en 95 kananaskis
en alberta en 2002 et finalement
huntsville en ontario en 2010
[Musique]